I was a super shy kid and I found it really hard to express myself...
...and I had a passion and I was really artistic...
...and I knew I needed to get it out into the world...
...but this inhibition was slowing me down from my passion.
I realized that around age 12 that I didn't like myself...
...so how was I expecting everybody else to like me and connect to me?
And I realized that I was scared.
And so, I made up this thing in my head...
...where it was one scary thing per day.
And whether that was just putting my hand up in class...
...or talking to the cute boy or just expressing myself in some way,...
...I had to put myself into that scary place.
So, I took on that way of being and expanded it throughout my whole life.
And I've got to this point where I am now:...
...the world's foremost professional mermaid underwater performance artist...
...and activist for the ocean animals, and I swim with great white sharks...
...and tiger sharks and whales and dolphins.
Thinking about doing something that you're scared of...
...is so much more scary than the action of actually doing it.